Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is clustered day.
We have two great teams that are gonna
attempt to fix a broken Kubernetes cluster broken
by the other team.
Now, if you want to win a clustered
t shirt, which I should probably have been
wearing today. However, if you want to win
a clustered t shirt, jump to Rawkode.livewin.
All you have to do is retweet a
tweet that will enter you into the draw,
and we will draw two winners of a
t shirt at the end of today's episode.
So Rawkode.livewin.
I will pop that back up later to
remind you all, but first I need to
thank our wonderful sponsors.
So first up is Teleport.
Teleport have been sponsoring a show for a
long time now. We have used Teleport every
single episode of clustered as an amazing tool.
I always say that every single cluster, every
production environment should have a Teleport.
Why? Well, you can use GitHub, Google, and
other OAuth based providers
to
commoditize access to your cluster in a secure
fashion that doesn't rely on SSH keys.
You can also do a pairing and debugging
like we're going to do today. We have
multiple people in a single session debugging a
production issue.
That kind of latency when fixing things is
invaluable.
I also wanna thank Equinix Medal. They have
provided the hardware for every single episode of
cluster two, and they also gave us a
code that you can all use to check
it out. So if you want to check
out Equinix Metal for 200 USD, which is
around one hundred hours of compute,
you can use the code Rawkode.
Go to Rawkode.live/metal
to find out more information. Equinix Metal is
a bare metal cloud. We don't use VMs
for clustered. We use big chunky machines with
tons of cores and tons of memory.
Why? Because it makes it more fun for
me. So go check out Equinix Metal and
have some fun with that code. Alrighty.
Now it's time to introduce our first team.
We are joined by team
Aerospike.
Hello, team Aerospike. How are you all doing?
Doing good.
Alright.
Can we please say hello? We'll start top
right and
feel free to introduce yourself, and we'll get
started just as soon as we've done that.
Angeli, would you like to go first?
Yeah. Hi. My name is Angeli. I am
a new grad DevOps engineer at Aerospike,
and I'm excited to participate in this,
event.
Awesome. Thank you. Jeff?
Yeah. Jeff McCormick.
I work for Aerospike
on their
database as a service project
and Kubernetes
developer.
Anyway, happy to be here.
I'm broadcasting
or coming to you today from San Antonio,
Texas. So,
anyway, happy to be here and happy to
give it a try.
Awesome. Thank you. And familiar face, Merrick.
Yeah. My name is Merrick Counts. I absolutely
love clustered. I learn something
new every single time I I I I'm
here.
I'm super happy that,
the rest of the gang, we're a new
team, so we're just kind of, this is
kind of a team building experience for us.
I'm super excited that they were willing to
join to join me and do this. And
and so yeah. Yeah. Super excited to be
here. Yeah. I work for Aerospike, obviously, on
their database as a service,
and
I work with Jeff. So yeah. Anyways.
Awesome. Thank you, sir. Awesome. You all for
saying hello.
We're gonna dive straight into this. We've got
two clusters to get with today, and you're
unfortunate team one. I don't know if forced
or unfortunate. I I guess it could go
either way. It depends on the cluster. Right?
So
let's pop up my screen share. We have
teleport. I have already modified your role, so
you do have access
to the Pexi Labs cluster.
I I can see someone's already ran LS,
so there's someone else that's already in my
session. But I have opened a session on
Pexi Labs control play in one. Now if
you can just all give me an echo
or something to let you know that you're
here, and we'll get things kicked off for
today.
Hello, hi. I'm not sure who hi was,
but hi.
Alright. We got some random characters. That's always
a good way to go too.
Alright. And one more high. Hopefully, not the
same high. But, however,
I'm pretty confident that we're all in a
session. You have forty minutes team Aerospike.
Best of luck. Take it away.
So I guess, yeah, we can set that
up.
I guess the first thing we do is
try to connect to the cluster and see
if
yeah. Uh-oh. No control plan.
Alright.
Maybe we check since this is kubeadm, maybe
we check
we can check the manifest, but we could
also just check to see if the kubelet's
running, just like system CTL.
The kubelet should be running
on this.
Definitely Kubernetes thing's running.
And
what appears to be a kubelet?
Yeah. I never just say there's a kubelet
running anymore because I never trust anything in
these clusters after they've been broken.
Who are we thinking team member spike?
I don't know. We can run system CTL
status on it.
I have also learned not to trust the
binaries.
Yeah. Why would you trust the binary?
Hello to everyone on the chat. Remember, you
can win a cluster t shirt at Rawkode.live/win.
So it says the container runtime network is
not ready.
Someone's opened them already. Come on.
Let me try the session from the web.
I quite like the the ping yahoo.com.
I never trust a ping to google.com either.
I usually go about off field and pick
something like that.
Just to challenge the ping command, you know.
Google is a bit easy.
So we have a kubelet running, appears to
be healthy, but no API server.
We're in the static manifest for the API
server. I mean, the timestamp on it doesn't
look like it had been changed, but I'm
assuming you don't trust the timestamp either.
Well, I mean, you wouldn't be able to
because you're not connecting the certs there. You're
connecting to the SSL.
You'd have to also curl with the proper
certs. Right?
It's true.
Are there any
endpoints that are not Let's
see here.
It shouldn't be. I I was gonna say,
can you also just do, like, a port
scan like, list of the ports and see
if it's actually on that port?
Oh, wait. I didn't see its port configuring
that.
Is it oh, its secure port is at
6443.
Mhmm.
We have to check one more. Yeah. It
is also there at 6443.
Yep. Looks alright to me.
Mhmm.
We could check the wait. Wait. And I'm
sorry if I I missed something that was
reading chat.
And thank you, Jeff, for typing because last
time I typed, I catted a binary file
and I'm a little scarred still from that.
Happened two weeks in a row. You'd never
believe it. It happened two weeks in a
row.
I was so happy when somebody else did
it. So I was just like, ah, phew.
Same thought.
Easy. So the other thing we could do
is check the cubelet because this is a
static pod. So if it's not running for
some reason, we could check the container runtime
that as well as
the kubelet logs for why it might not
be running, if it's not running. Or do
we think that we just don't have access?
Maybe I'm a little behind.
I haven't I don't know that we verified
that it's actually running and listening on that
port.
Yeah. You said something interesting earlier. Can we
port scan or list the ports? I I
think that's a good thread to pull that.
Can we grep that on the yeah.
So I don't think it's actually running
for reasons.
I think you're right. Can
you get logs from the API server?
So Remember the big log file
position there.
So container log Actually, could you check template.
Was Mark, are you gonna say that, or
should I continue?
No. You continue. I I I stopped. Yeah.
So you can go to varlog containers or
varlog pods, and that will allow you to
see the logs for containers that spun up
temporarily.
So there is an API server directory or
something there depending on the colors.
Yeah. Directory.
There we go.
Alright. So they screwed with STD.
I hate you guys.
Every time I see STD in a log
file, I'm ready to go home. So Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So there's a couple things here.
There's actually two certs I was going to
say that they could screw up that I
I can think of off the top of
my head. You have the one that allows
you
but
you have the cert talk to etcd. So
can we actually just cat the etcd
comp file?
Not the binary.
Not the oh, yes, please. Not the binary.
If you go into the manifest
go into the manifest. There should be a
manifest that describes etcd. Right there.
Right there. The the
the etcd. Yaml.
And here's where it's going to define its
certs,
and then we gotta make sure that the
API server is loading the right certs as
well.
Oh gosh.
Did you check to see if SCC was
running first?
Good
point.
It does appear to be.
It it's running as a static pod manifest,
so it wouldn't be in system CTL,
I don't think. Okay.
Well, it seems to be running anyway. So
Well, if you had the ethic d control,
I don't know if there's a nicer way
to say that command. You could run health
and status commands, but I think you'll need
to install it.
It's c d dash client, maybe.
And then there is a bunch of setup,
which I never remember.
So I'm gonna grab a cheat sheet that
I always use.
I was gonna say that you have to
pass it to Yeah. The from the API
version and a
bunch of other crap.
It's not the one I normally use. Where's
the one I normally use?
Oh, I'm never gonna figure that out because
I use Dot go.
That's the one.
Do you mind if I paste onto your
session?
Please do. Alright. So that exports all the
stuff that you need, and then you should
be able to use etcd control get. And
as you'll see, you now have the permissions
that I've replicated. So you can maybe
use some other etcd control commands to work
out what's going on.
So it said permission denied
for the get.
I I'm wondering if they changed those certs
on us.
Try an entity control
health or status. I can't remember.
I think it's health, but I don't remember
either.
Yeah. Unknown command. That may just be it
is.
I don't know. People don't play with that
too directly. Right?
That's too hard.
I'm looking, Jeff.
Give me a second.
Try at c z dash dash help.
Endpoint health and endpoint status might be a
good one to run.
Think you have to pass an endpoint for
that.
Nope. Both returned good.
But I think their entity customer might be
alright.
What else could the permissions be?
Problem. So, actually, we could look at the
API server config. Does it use the same
certs as we're using here? So is it
use did they just update the the certs
that it's trying to use to communicate with
it to bad certs or screw with them?
Potentially.
You could always go into the PKI directory
and check some file timestamps with a superficial
check.
But
we do have someone from Pixielabs, Philip, in
the chat saying not a search problem.
Oh.
But where else do we have permissions?
File system?
I mean, is it a permissions problem?
Or oh, actually, they could have changed where
it's
it's endpoint that it's trying to hit to
be the wrong endpoint.
Did we validate that it's actually going to
the right endpoint?
Oh, does etcd have our back? I don't.
Kevin also confirming that permission denied comes from
etcd,
and it wouldn't be a CEREC issue. So
definitely not CEREC.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Lots of confirmations. Stop looking
at this, sir.
Alright. So it's not certs, permission denied
coming from etcd.
It could be the user,
like so I guess our back, our user
doesn't have it. I don't know how to
configure
RBAC. Let me look at RBAC or etcd.
So And from the Hang on the Pixilabs
t l
what'd you say?
The Hang from the Pixilabs team is saying
a reminder that the entity control get also
failed.
That that's important.
K.
Get also failed.
Could you also do the etcctl
user list?
I'm not I'm not an etcd person,
But
Oh, it's always just jury commands. I
thought you went on to one earlier. Oh,
well.
Yeah. Did you try user list? My session
broke. I'm reconnecting.
I'll be right back.
There are hints in that route directory. Might
be a good time to check the first
one out.
Yep. I agree.
And we got some confirmation from Philip and
Vahang. So firstly, the entity image has not
been changed.
And secondly,
I promise you, this is less than the
store that it's seen.
You modified STD. That's as sinister as it
gets on clustered. Come on.
Alright. So they're saying root to root. That
looks like Linux file permissions.
Yeah.
That's where my my brain was going to.
So where's the etcd file database live?
Oh,
is it etcd that's having a problem loading
its file?
Like, it doesn't have permission to open the
database file?
It's just something data. Yeah. That's helpful. Barlib
etcd.
Jeff, could we look at varlib etcd?
Yeah.
And look at the file permissions on the
file?
I'm sorry. What's the path again?
Varlib etcd,
I think, what the yeah.
Member.
Well, everything's owned by Roo, didn't it? So
Yep.
They have said that the failed permission is
a red herring,
And we've been encouraged to run the entity
control dash h once again. But no disk
limits failed permissions, but we do need to
be curious about the root root.
Well, let's take a look at dash help
here.
Oh,
I think I've worked it out.
There's a
a user flag that can take a password
there.
You wanna try the get again?
Passing on the user?
Try rip.
Yeah.
Hey.
They've turned on authentication or at least
non
x five zero nine authentication.
Can we just turn that off?
What's the easiest way here? Like so I
honestly don't know. I I've never done this
with it.
Let's go take a look at the entity
manifest.
I'm not entirely sure.
Let's see let's see if we can find
out if it's in here. Oh, let me
jump back over.
Oh, wait. Wait. That's cert auth. I don't
think that's
Yeah. We've been told to look at entity
control dash h again.
Or maybe that was maybe we're celebrating the
fact that we did look at the control
dash h.
Not in the manifest.
Okay.
Alright. So
Would be
Let's see.
Member add route maybe or
So there's a change to the password. Do
an off disable.
Yeah. Off disable is good.
Well, it doesn't turn it off.
Oh, you'll need your dad. Yeah. You got
it.
So now we're looking to see if we
have an API server coming online.
So maybe worth checking or tailing those logs
again,
see what happens.
And there we go.
Alright. So the nodes aren't ready. So this
maybe says something with the cubelet.
We could give them just a second, but
I'm guessing if they mess with that CD,
it's they're not coming back.
Yep.
I guess maybe we check the
can you actually just do, like, a describe
on
the node?
Overcommitted.
No. No. It's not never mind. It's not
overcommitted.
Sorry.
We've got twenty minutes left.
Wait a minute. Loads of things.
Like, are the notes taking too many resources?
Got plenty of memory.
Yeah.
Yeah. These are fairly chunky bare metal machines.
So
Yep.
So what else causes a node to report
its status as not ready?
The labels.
So I I apologize. One question. I my
terminal keeps not tracking the like, tailing his
things.
Am I doing something to screw that up?
Or do I just have to Resize it
like a pixel. It it seems to kick
it back into shape as as a external
JS bug.
So, unfortunately, we do just have to work
around it. So if you do think that
it's not tracking properly, a small resize of
your window will give it a nudge.
Just don't resize it too much because then
it throws off for everybody.
Terminals are hard. I'm on I three, so
the resize was taking up to changing the
half of the screen.
Oh,
well, we'll see how we get on.
Alright. Let's let's work out this not ready.
Alright.
Now those tents can just be removed manually.
You can always try that and see if
they come back. Right?
I mean, did they cordon them? I could
have just cordoned them.
I I I don't know. You'd have to
do a
describe or an edit on a note.
But Philip in the chat says they weren't
expecting not ready status. So
Uh-oh.
So we may have some collateral damage. This
is what you get.
Well
Yeah. That's the way it goes sometimes.
Yeah. Let's try and edit nodes. You just
remove it. If it comes back, we can
look at the events and we can work
our way.
But edit nodes, pick
hexylabs dash control plane dash one.
Oh, well. Worker one came back at least.
So
Is this just etcd being slow with,
Yeah. It's back. There we go.
Yes.
I'm about to debug something. It wasn't broken.
Always fun with Kubernetes.
Well, it looks good.
Could
you
could you check the stateful set? There should
be a database in the stateful set.
Looks good.
You're gonna have to run get pods now.
It put us all out of misery.
Yeah.
So we wanna do this.
Let's see.
Clustered.
Puzzled people always call this your cluster d.
Maybe I should rename it.
Can you also do, like, a dash capital
a and see if they, like, did something
sneaky in a different namespace?
Like,
just it don't do git deployment. Do, like,
git pods and then do cache.
Or you could you actually do git all
dash capital a. Yeah. I think rubber cable
is right here. Like, you haven't checked the
web page or the service. You don't even
know if it's working or not working.
It could be fine. Right?
How do we check the web page again?
I I can try curl on local host
30,000.
V one is working.
So now we try to update to v
two.
So we just go ahead and edit the
deployment and go to v two?
That's the mission.
Uh-oh.
It So
image never pooled.
This is either networking
You would have to get pod dash o
yamo. Yeah. There we go.
It's not installed. It's container d, isn't it?
So they have an image pool policy of
never.
And the image is still set as v
one, which looks interesting.
Yeah.
Wait. Wait. Oh,
you you grep the one that's running.
Grep the or
do the get pod on the one that's
not running.
It's
the the six q yeah.
Image
never pull.
Right. I think that we need to
change the image pull policy.
It's like they did something else and expected
us to look at that image pool policy.
Couldn't have been that simple. And now it
can't pull the image.
Image pool backup.
URL looks okay.
What next? So that would be that
could be, like, the container runtime, which would
be going to pull this. Right?
Yep.
Yep. Container d. Jeff, maybe we check
oh, what were you saying, David?
Yes. These are container d clusters. Container d
is responsible for for pulling the image.
I was gonna say maybe we could check
the logs on container d on the worker
node since this would have to be running
on the worker node.
Would you like me to open a session
on the worker node?
Yeah.
Alright.
Opening that.
All yours. Take it away.
You have twelve minutes.
No pressure.
So does container reach up with any CLI
tools that allow you to pull images?
I was wondering about that image is definitely
out there. I can see it.
You know?
So we have access to cry control,
c r I c t l, and to
CTR.
Those are two command line options for working
with continuity.
Anybody ever wanting to know, nerd c t
l is a fantastic one that is like
a docker compatible API for container d.
Install it.
Yeah.
Oh, we got an error method.
That's interesting.
Google.code.com.
So
it looks like
it looks like they made it so that
they gave a certificate that's valid for things
that aren't GCR.
So my image comes from GitHub container registry,
and you're getting certificates for Google
Container Registry, gcr.io.
But how how can they
how can they modify that resolution?
DNS.
Wait. Can we look at the hints? Are
there hints on this file this one?
Oh, you haven't I mean, you maybe look
at the host files first, so the resolve
con.
Oh.
Alright.
I don't know what dot 82 is, but
I'm guessing that's wrong.
I can go look.
Yeah. That worked,
didn't it? So was the I missed that
because I was joining the session. So did
they add something to the host file?
Yeah. They overwrote Yeah. G c r. So
I commented it out,
and then that ran,
which means
back on the other,
now we should be able to, get it
to pull that image maybe.
There we go.
Alright. What next?
Actually, Jeff,
could you just
they did it on both.
Thank you.
So what happens when you run get pods
now?
Well, maybe try deleting our back off pod.
Okay.
Yeah. Rub our cable in the chat with
the same suggestion there.
Good call.
Hey. It's working.
Or it's maybe maybe it may be working.
Alright?
Alright. So they got you both a dual
policy and a DNS check.
And that is the v two image.
I can pull that up here too
if you wanna confirm.
Yep.
That's interesting. Okay.
Sometimes
that happens. Yeah. I really need to work
on it.
Alright. I think that works, isn't it? You
have to dance. Well done.
Probably the end of our time.
Because if there is such a thing as
easy. Right?
Well, that
he's worked through that problem after problem. Good
job.
Etsy d is is a good one. You
know, honestly, I can say, like,
I can't tell you how many times Etsy
d has
bitten me in the hind end.
Yeah. It's it's a good one to actually
troubleshoot. I it's been forever since I've touched
it last. So
Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not an SPD expert at all.
So
Well, at least now we've all learned a
valuable production hack.
It's a entity control off disable.
Like, that's now my my go to. So,
you know, awesome.
That's exactly what you wanna do in production
is disable all security.
Alright. Well,
you just managed to work through all of
those problems with six to seven minutes left.
So well done, team aerospike. I'm gonna ask
you to kindly go watch from YouTube, and
I will invite on our friends at Pixielabs
to see what you have in store for
them. So thanks a lot. Good job, and
I'll speak to you also.
Thank Alright.
I'll just cut my off there. Sorry, mate.
But we'll wait here until we get our
team from Pixie Labs over. I'll also remind
you that you can win a cluster t
shirt by going to rockode.livewin.
Cool. Let's see. We've got a few people
joining now.
So we got Philip,
Kjell,
and Ben.
Hey. How's it going?
It's going well.
Thanks for having us. Fun to watching someone
else fix your broken cluster?
Yeah. Absolutely. Work to that team,
to aerospike.
Yeah.
Awesome. We actually had one more break left,
but
it somehow got overwritten.
So,
yeah, we we added a network block on
ghcr.i0
using
XDP and EBPF.
And I don't know. So maybe the container
got cached or something like that. So, unfortunately,
it did not show up. But you could
actually see it in one of the,
I think it was the CRI CTL
calls. Like, there was no network resolution there.
So yeah.
Unfortunately, something went wrong. So maybe we just
kept it cached, the container
See if I have something. I mean, I
don't wanna speak for them, but I haven't
seen eBPF breaks on this before. Nobody ever
gets them. It's it's one of those, like,
black boxes. It's really difficult to, like, understand
where the eBPF is happening and how to
how to get around it. So that would
have been
will show you that one of the network
interfaces has been messed with,
which is
which is what we were hoping for.
I
guess we'll send them over as part of
the show notes, but if anybody wants to
see them. But, unfortunately, did not get to
see them in action. So that's Oh, well.
Well, I'm looking forward to reading that at
least anyway.
Alright. Can we start in the top right?
Please say hello, introduce yourself. We'll work our
way around clockwise,
and then we'll hand you over a cluster.
Hi, everyone. I'm Philip.
I am an engineer at New Relic working
on Pixi.
Yeah. Oh, and my Twitter handle is at
Phil because.
Cool.
I'm Vihang Mehta. I'm another engineer at,
at Pixi, now,
a part of New Relic.
And I think this will be a common
theme. Philip, me, and Michelle all sort of
work on the same
team at Pixi.
Yep. And I
I am Michelle Nguyen.
Just to give some context about what Pixi
actually is, we are an open source CNCF
sandbox project.
And, basically, our thing is that we are
a real time debugging platform. You deploy Pixi
to your cluster. You know, you can deploy
using YAMLs. You can run through our CLI.
But, you just deploy Pixi. And right there,
out of the box, you get a bunch
of baseline visibility metrics and information about your
cluster. So we use eBPF to collect things
like full body HTTP
requests. We get,
you know, continuous profiling. So a bunch of
interesting stuff without you really having to do
anything but deploy Pixie.
So, yeah, definitely check it out. You should
check out px.dev.
That's our website with all our information and
docs and links links out to our blog.
You can join our Slack community. So I
think that's slackin.px.dev.
But, yeah, just check us out. We're super
excited to just, like, get people using our
stuff. Leave comments, feedback, and we love contributors
as well.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing. And if people
do want to learn more about Pexi Labs,
they can go to Rawkode.live
and search for Pexi Labs. I did a
ninety
minute stream with Natalie. I think it was
around six six or seven months ago when
we dived into Pexi. Was an awesome product.
It was a lot of fun. Encourage people
to check it out.
Alright. I see someone's already joined my session,
so awesome. Let's get everyone else in there.
I'm gonna pop my screen share up now.
I've opened the session on airspace control plane
one.
Feel free to join. Give me an echo.
Let me know you're there. Thank you. We've
got one. We got two.
It always helps when people tell me to
type in. Yeah. Here we go. Perfect.
Alright.
Have
have around forty minutes. Best of luck. Take
it away.
Okay.
Let me let me copy over some
commands I want.
Always nice to see the k nine Yeah.
And then getting k nine s.
This might be interesting because sometimes it doesn't
quite work with the x term.
Oh, okay.
There we go. You
know?
People have tried to use it before, and
it's it's okay in the web. So I'll
keep it there. Oh. Oh. So as long
as you're fine with that. Yeah. If you
could see it, it's fine. I'll just try
and not use the terminal one for this
bit. We're all good. Feel free to use
it. Okay. Okay.
I guess I'll see what we can do.
Okay. So I'll just do this for now.
Yes. That's our part of the thing. No
control plan there. Connection was refused.
Oh,
okay.
Got any ideas.
Okay. So no control plan.
We kinda need one of those. Right?
Yeah.
Wait. Do do you wanna get that CD
con control and just just double check?
Case.
Where did we get it before?
App install at c d
dash client, and then I still got the
cheat sheet here with this setup. I
just use this one all the time.
At c d hyphen client. Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Alright. I will paste in the setup for
you if you want.
Oh, sure. Yeah. Looks
good. There you go.
Okay.
So I'm not as familiar with this. Michelle,
what do you what command do you run
here?
Oh,
get guest said that that CD is running,
so we're probably okay on that. Yeah. Think
it's fine now. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Okay. So
control plane is missing. Do we have the
cubelet?
You have a kubelet.
Do you have an API server?
Just kubectl.
Sorry.
Alright. You got Kubectl,
scheduler, controller manager, Kubectl. You have no API
server.
No API server. Yep. You definitely need one
of those too.
Yeah.
Okay.
Control planes are overrated.
The null channel is Marek from.
When he messages that, you you may wanna
pay attention.
Control plane is overrated. Oh. Oh. I I
think he's just joking at it. I I
would be able to take a the
static manifest and see or maybe the logs
for the APIs server. It would be a
good starting point.
How do you find those? Is it under,
like, varlog or something like that?
Varlog containers or varlog pods depending on how
much view you want of the cluster.
API
Tube API server.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
So
connection refused.
Cannot reach.
Wait. No.
It's not certs. Okay. I'm just trying to
think.
Well, what did the other team think? Well,
the the port looks fishy. Right? One two
six nine? Yeah. I don't think that's the
standard port.
I have not seen the port number before.
Yeah.
Yeah. Good catch. Let's look at the manifest
for the
for the API server.
Yeah. Kevin's saying the port looks wrong to
him too, so let's go check that. Wait.
The manifest is at Etsy.
Kubernetes manifest? Yep. The one? Yeah.
Oh.
You can either use them or a cat
it with a pager. Yeah. That's a good
way to do it. I mean, it is.
I thought someone's gonna have to, like, delay
case c d, like, ran overuse of cat.
I definitely do that all.
Is trying to connect to +1 269. What
does that CD say?
It is
2379?
Right. Yeah.
They just they just narrow
down. Right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Did not know you could go just edit
files like the manifest in the file system
like this. Said 2379.
Right? Yeah. Yeah. That's the one. That's the
one.
We need to restart anything?
The kubelet will detect that change. If you
wanna speed that up a little bit, you
can do a system d control restart kubelet.
Oh,
system control. Sorry. System CTL. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Okay. That's what I thought.
System CTL. System CTL is gonna change something
else.
That's the kernel tool.
There we go.
Should we check it? Yeah. Oh, dot slash
dot slash.
Yeah.
Not there yet.
Coming low, I think.
Should we check the API server logs again?
Yep. I mean yeah.
Var logs. Right?
Yeah. I have it in the history. Let
me check.
Var log.
Oh, I guess the the container ID might
change. So
I would hope so.
Yeah. That's the same one. Right? And eight
hasn't incremented,
so
I'm not confident that we have an API
server.
Alright.
3219.
Okay. Yeah. This is four minutes ago still.
So
What else is wrong here?
If you check the kubelet log?
Yeah. Let's let's before we restart.
Oh, is it not in the same place?
Maybe in continue? The kubelet logs, because it's
not system d service, you'll need to use
journal control dash flu kubelet.
The journal c d l dash f l
u
and then kubelet.
So that's standard. That just means it can't
reach the API server you get.
Too.
It it could just be that our API
server
Oh, I see. Oh, goo Kubernetes.
What did you notice? Oh. A Goobernetes.
Yep.
The static manifest bunch of Goobers.
Kidding.
But you know what that message mean?
The static manifest location has been changed potentially.
So it's not actually reading the manifest from
Etsy Kubernetes
manifest. Where is that configured?
A
kill command if you want me to share.
Yeah. The system control cat and a service
name
gives you quite a lot of cool information.
Alright.
So there's a there's a
there's a bunch of files
listed there that I would start. Bootstrap tubelet
and
a bunch of other stuff there. Right? Can
you can you see Google, Netiz?
Oh, it's gonna be in one of those
config files somewhere. You don't need to start.
Right.
There's no bootstrap here?
You may wanna start in FireLib kubect config
dot YAML.
Typing on camera is always fun. Right?
Yep. It's
not just three of us watching. It's,
you know, a few dozen.
Don't tell me. Don't tell me.
Oh. Oh, that were that was it. That
was it. You go. I saw it.
Nice. Okay. There you go. Static pod path.
We've ungoovered the cluster.
I
I would definitely restart that kubelet again. Save
yourself a few minute.
Alright. Now we can make a cup of
tea, open a beer, have a sandwich, wait
for the API server.
Not yet.
Note that we want journal control.
Pause it, maybe. I would expect to see
API server and a PS coming up pretty
soon.
Okay. Oh, yeah.
But then I expect a lot of things.
I'm wrong all the time.
But, I mean, I hope you get an
API server soon.
Right. Nothing yet.
If you go back to the logs, what
I think I
think we're missing some files.
The CNI plugin not initialized
isn't is about or is it log?
You got a new error message there. No?
Failed it. No. Okay. The least one you
can ignore. This is still just API server
missing stuff so far.
Well, do we know if the API server
is on yet? I don't think it is.
Right? No. No. It's not on. You know,
what's preventing it?
We may wanna check for API server logs
again and hope we get a new pod
and container increment ID. We don't we don't
really wanna see 8 dot log anymore.
Pods. Right? No. Kubernetes pods. No pods is
right. Barlog pods. Just pods.
Kube API.
Oh, I That's 8. Log. Yeah. That's the
old one. Yeah.
I mean, you can catch it, but I
don't think we'll see anything new from that
fail.
Sometimes you miss a t.
+1 935.
No. O '2 '19 '30 '5. Yeah. I
don't think that's changed.
Right.
So we haven't had the Kubelet attempt to
start a new API server yet, it looks
like.
Well, we could tail it, but I don't
think it's gonna
tell us anything.
Yep.
No new logs. Yeah. That's not spat log
out and
I
don't think it'll Sixty hours. I don't think
it'll log.
How long has our cumulative been running out
of interest?
That looks like Seventeen. We restarted it three
minutes ago.
Yeah.
So some more Kubelet configs here.
I think Do
does anyone know if Bootstrap kube kube config
needs to exist?
Because I'm pretty sure it doesn't exist.
It does not need to exist. No.
Alright.
Alright. I think you should be looking at
the journal command again and maybe take it
slow, I think.
I'm assuming
we we could be missing something.
I wonder if I can type this.
Is it gonna straight well, okay. Unable to
write event.
Connection refused. Yeah.
One is to
to the API server. Right?
What is
usually at 6443? I thought that was the
API server? Yeah. Which we don't have. So
we're looking for something that would tell us
why the API server was not started.
Yep.
That's CNI plugin not initialized.
Okay.
I feel like that
the CNI plugin isn't dependent upon the API
server, is it?
It is not. No. An API server isn't
dependent on CNI either. Ah. Okay. Could not
process manifest file,
cube API server YAML,
couldn't parse this pod.
Please check config file.
And I lost that.
So there's a adder and your static manifest
for the API server.
Where was that?
Etsy Kubernetes manifest cube dash API server dot
YAML.
I spent a lot of time in that
file, strangely enough. And
the error message pointed to line a 30,
if I believe correctly.
Interesting
character. I
guess that's it.
That was said far too confidently.
Oh, wait. That was the that was the
error.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean, that would definitely cause the YAML
parsing to fail. So I mean, I'm not
saying that's the only error, of course, but
it's definitely a problem.
Also, I'm pretty sure this is
flipped. Oh, nice catch. I didn't notice that.
Comments helped.
Oh. Oh.
Russell. Good catch, Russell. Oh, and
James as well with that catch. Well done.
Yeah.
But here too, I believe.
And team here, I respect shushing everybody in
the comments.
So Robert Campbell says the status looks out
of place. It it's okay for the status
to be empty
in this. Oh, I'm sure that the status
will get filled out later. Right? So
safe.
Yep. Maybe misplaced,
but
Alright. Let's see if it's running.
Not yet.
You can try CTL?
Yeah. You you could try a restart. The
like, so the way the Kiplet monitors the
static manifest directory, it can take, like, up
to four minutes, I think, before it will
detect the change and restart it. A restart
of the Kiplet will
it a little bit faster.
Should we journal CTL again?
Well,
let's check let's check this manifest file here.
I have a feeling there's a bunch of
issues here.
I think you have an API server now.
Alright. Let me check.
Damn it.
Not yet.
Is journal CTL still complaining?
Or is the are the logs still complaining
about
any manifest or something?
Well, it still can't talk to the API
server, which is because API server doesn't exist.
Connection fused.
I don't see any other
errors,
which is good.
Should we try this just to make sure?
I mean, you can even grab for API
server.
Alright. So now
That's a kubelet restart. Yep.
These are still infos.
Here's the first error. Could not process manifest
file. Delete me dot YAML.
That kinda looks suspicious. Alright. Let's see.
Where do you see that? Sorry. I never
caught that. Oh.
Oh, it's It's all good. You can let's
just go take a look at it.
Yeah. You'll you'll see it.
What is here? I'm pretty sure I should
just delete this thing. Safe networking. Wait. Woah.
Woah. Woah.
If it's a trick a trick? Oh,
wait. Do we have another networking policy
manifest?
How about I do this?
Well,
I mean, I don't wanna
be too confident in my statement, but I
don't think the kubelet would even apply that
to your cluster.
If it just exists?
Because
yeah. Because the way the static pods work
is that it actually creates projection pods. I
don't think putting a network policy in that
directory will do anything.
I mean, I could be wrong, and I
often am. The null channel says it will
try to run every manifest in that folder,
apparently.
Oh, so that maybe add them as a
blocker stopping it from deploying anything else afterwards
because it can actually deploy
a network policy from that directory. That's a
cool break. Yeah. Yeah.
Nice.
Alright. So let
let's go back to restarting and looking at
logs.
This
is the way to do it.
Alright. So far, unable
to find data and memory cache
from CRI stats.
I think that's alright.
I think you're good. Right?
That's a healthy equivalent in API server.
Nope. Nothing
yet.
And we did you delete that file?
I moved it to home.
Oh, cube VIP
is
readable by other folks.
The other ones are not.
Don't know if that Pretty sure the kubelet
runs other.
But, I mean, you can check that too.
We
didn't we have that CD? It won't work.
Or STD worked. Right? Yeah. The STD can
work. Actually running this. Yeah. Yeah.
It should be running everything.
Do we have an API server yet, or
do we need to start panicking?
No.
Not yet. Still time to panic.
See.
Alright. Let's see. Cloud Fire.
I can stop scrolling. Please just let me
know.
So oh, no. There's connection refused.
Before the connection refused, it says there's waiting
for API server, actually, if you if you
scroll up.
Waiting for yep. No.
Creating container manager based on.
Should we just look
through error logs?
Do we have an API server log yet?
That's not it dot log.
Oh, good good call.
No. That looks like the old one. Yeah.
Oh. Okay.
So maybe we still need a CNI plug
in thing.
Or maybe I'm wrong.
There's a there's that log about the CNI
not being initialized yet.
Okay. Let's because I I I'm really confused.
So I I feel embarrassed to do this.
But we
have a bunch of static manifests and it's
a Kubernetes manifest.
Can we verify
that any of the control plane components are
running via PS?
Oh, it can just come up with that.
Yeah. There should be a KubeScheduler,
a controller manager, an API server, and NCD.
Alright.
So NCD
is up there.
So STD and GoogLeP we have, but nothing
else.
Nothing else.
So we expect
scheduler.
So I'm
curious if we journal flu the kubelet again
and just grab for API server,
if there's anything. And if not, I'm not
actually convinced that it's trying to start it.
Yeah. That's it. Just trying to speak to
the API server.
So I'm not convinced it's trying to start
the static manifest.
Yeah. Right?
We can also check hints.
Yeah. We do have hints. We do have
hints.
Alright. Trust split verify.
Sometimes more is not better.
These are subtle.
Should we go to three?
Yeah. We got fifteen minutes left. Let's take
a look at three and see if we
got any ideas.
Alright. Okay. I think you fixed that one.
I think we fixed that one.
Yeah.
Alright. So we do have Marek saying that
he would have at this point, he would
expect the kubelet to try and start the
API server.
So I know your ports. Okay.
I could really fix that one too.
I'm gonna make a suggestion, and this is
a bit wild, but sometimes this stuff works.
Okay. If we go to the manifest directory
and let's move stuff out of it except
for etcd.
Okay. So
let me
yeah. Move yeah. That'll that'll work. Go for
it. That's the worst that could happen.
Alright. And then restart?
Restart the kubelet. Yeah. So I'd expect to
see kubelet disappear at c d. Stay as
it is.
And then we can add on the API
server and see if it helps.
CubeVip is still there
and so is that CD.
The SDD is the only one left in
that directory. Right?
Yes.
I believe so.
Yeah.
Should we move the API server in then?
A cube head is that? It
is indeed hard to write good heads.
I hope that a kill made his name
on cube head.
Yeah. We can try that.
19788.
Yeah.
Oh, give it I'm just curious if it
comes back. That's all. I mean.
Well, we can
restart the kubelot.
America's saying, does the kubelot shut down pods
when the static manifest is removed? I thought
it did.
Maybe maybe I am wrong. Oh. I think
I think it does. I do think it
does.
Well,
what was in delete me?
That was just a networking policy. Right? So
I think that break was that the because
it's not a pod,
the kubectl actually stopped on that. So maybe
I'm confused.
Yeah.
I guess we try to move the API
server
manifest
back in here. Yeah. Let's give it a
go.
Okay.
Nothing yet. You feeling brave enough to kill
minus nine at CD?
Because if right. At this point, it feels
that the Kubelet is not starting anything. Right?
Yeah. Let's check the Kubelet config. That's what
null channel is saying.
I got the boring way.
I think he needs the viral load
to let Oh, okay. Yep.
Alright. Ten minutes to go. It was
config.
Yep.
Oh, that's oh, wait. Zeros are okay.
So it's okay to see zero seconds, I
believe.
Oh, I see something. But I'm gonna I'm
gonna leave leave it. The held z port?
You can ignore that.
I'm surprised there's no header message for this,
though.
Memory swap?
That's is that okay to be empty? Yes.
But you're you're close.
Yeah. Mark's given it up already in the
chat. I was trying not to mention it,
but max pods one.
Oh, there can only be one pod running.
Ah.
It's just a
Delete. A 10. That's a good one. Yeah.
I I expected an error message from there
and from that. Robert Cable says, possibly no
error message because report frequency is off. Well,
I guess there's not an error. Right?
It did exactly what we told it to
do.
Normally,
would say couldn't start your pod because without
the max pod. Like, if you have the
10 limit and you hit it, it's very
vocal that you hit it, but then maybe
it's different for static pods. I'm not entirely
sure.
But good break. Nice one, Nice.
Yeah.
Hey.
How's up?
Nice.
Oh.
Oh, did it wrong.
Do that.
There we go. Oh, lots of stuff.
Oh, boy.
Oh, there's probably a deployment that's, like, making
thousand and the replicas.
Oh, a 79
requested.
And I could just I'm there straight with
it delete. Like, go away. We don't we
don't care. Oh, I get NGINX here. What
what is busy bugs doing over here?
Hey. Robert, table said this is the less
is not less is not more. Yeah. There
was a hint about that, wasn't there? Yeah.
So
Postgres is running.
Yeah.
NGINX is DDoSing our cluster.
And
nothing about why this is pending.
Be that NGINX doesn't
sorry?
It could be the pod limit that we're
still reaching.
It should be terminating these. Right?
So I mean, they they are terminating. But
your worker online? Is the Kubelet online for
that worker?
Oh, we don't know.
Do we have a session for that yet?
Oh, you can see it from k n
check nodes. Yeah.
Oh, yep.
Yeah. So if we don't get a kubelet
report and status, those terminates will never complete.
Alright.
Open a session.
There.
I will remember to join the session.
No cubelet. That's a problem.
Another problem is six minutes left.
VLC?
I do not remember these. FLU is the
one I tend to use. FLU.
Could not find the container destock it.
Yep.
I would apologize to Pixi Labs, but you
touched ETCD.
Does your ACTL tell me anything about container
d running?
No. Yeah.
I mean, you can use system controls data
as container d for a quick
quick look.
Claims to be running.
It does.
Is it at the right sock?
Oh, Kubernetes dot sock.
Yeah. That would be a problem.
Where is the container deconfig?
Use system control cat. It is always your
friend. Oh, d units.
Just user bin container d.
Where do you see that? Yep. Yep.
Exec start. Oh, no. That's just the that's
just the exec.
Oh oh, my bad. My bad.
Yeah. That is a good directory or something.
You can check-in slash e t c for
a container config file.
That that would be the default location at
least.
Google. Google. Alright. I love it when the
cursor just lands right on the break.
Yeah.
Oh, I think you might have had a
typo.
Oops.
Good catch.
Nice. And a
I can type sometimes.
You know, I was told from the container
team that's print out container, but I still
call it container d.
I don't think I've ever heard Amazon say
there's a container d team meant to say
it as container.
I guess we can
restart Kubelet too.
That wouldn't hurt. Yep.
Can do a system control restart kubelet.
Oh, that was a status. I thought I
definitely typed restart.
Alright.
Yeah. Interesting, James. Is it Nerd Control or
I think it officially, it's Nerd Control.
NerdyControl.
Yeah. I'm not I'll need to Not nerd.
Not nerd cuddle.
Nerd cuddle. I mean
favorite My favorite was Quebec del. So you
know? Quebec.
So many ways. Alright. You have a kubelet.
I that should be reporting statuses. Your API
server, hopefully, is now
terminated a whole bunch of yo. That it
looks better. Oh, that's node.
Nope. The node's not ready yet.
Should we tail the logs?
I would check your should put logs on
that worker again then.
Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, it's just not started yet? Is
that it? Or did you restart it there?
No. It's 55.
It's running?
Started Kubelet as run once.
Yeah.
That's not cool.
Started Kubelet as what run once?
Yeah.
I think they've broken more stuff in your
Kubelet config
or container d
config.
And but there's a bunch of
interesting things in that log mess. Well,
you know, we can we can check that.
Okay.
No no hints on the worker node.
I mean, I can just throw something out
there. You do not need a container deconfig
file.
Alright.
But you're also gonna wanna remove that run
once in the kubelet. That is a system
decent if you're not aware.
So you need the system control
cat
kubelet, and that will tell you where the
unit fail is.
That's the sneaky one for people. It depends
on if you're comfortable with
system d.
Yeah. Lab systemdsystemkubelet.service
jump into that fail.
Wait. Sorry. It was lib The
first line after the cat. Yeah. Just just
copy it. Oh, okay. Okay.
That was interesting.
This seems fine. Right?
This is where my system do acknowledge and
let me down. I would maybe add to
the service.
I wonder if run once is a default
if you had to add type simple.
Someone in the comments help us out. What's
the best way for this to get fixed?
Let's
see.
Oh, it's a cubit config. Cubit config. I
saw it in system d config.
Is that corrected?
There it is. Ah, run one. Yeah.
I wonder what the use case for that
is. Someone go find that PR.
Alright. Our time is up, but we're close.
So let's let's see this. Alright.
Oh, yeah. Mara said it's also a system
deconfig. Yeah. Thanks for that.
Yeah. You'll need to do a daemon reload
because we modified the
the units
fail.
Alright.
It's just system System CTL.
Reload.
And daemon dash reload.
Yeah.
They just delete the kubelet. Them and reload
will reload all the unit files,
and then you can restart the kubelet from
there.
Alright.
Maybe it's working. I don't know.
Yep.
It Working heads up.
Hasn't terminated anything yet.
But
Do you wanna do you wanna edit the
deployment?
Oh, no.
Why?
Edit the deployment for
for cluster d. So if it works, you
know, it'll just start. Alex saying you're trippers.
He handed you a dumpster fire.
Kevin suggested that people are playing the long
game and adding features to the just for
use on clustered. So if that's why Rawkode
was added, that would be great question.
Let's just do if not present,
and hope that it's been cached.
Scheduler is broken.
You can bypass the scheduler. I
don't think I know how.
Edit the deployment, jump down to the templates
back, and add node name.
My favorite hack on cluster. They do it
all the time.
A template
It's just that. Bet. Yep. So you're in
the yep. And then there, add node name
with a capital n for name, and then
just do
air spike worker one. Air spike worker one.
Yep. There's Russell in the comments. Here comes
the Rawkode scheduler.
Honestly, I tell everybody about that trick. I'm
like, we don't need a scheduler. Like, just
never waste time fixing the scheduler on cluster.
Something something is
Yeah. Something is controlled busy box.
Is there another break? Airspike.
Come on.
Does that busy box keep coming back?
I was deleting it at the wrong level.
Alright.
Alright. Alright.
Space.
Alright. Do we have a clustered v two?
Woah. What's going on with the cluster deploy?
I'll set it in the day.
How many replica sets do we have?
Interesting.
Oh. Oh, that
one's gone. Right?
Oh, is the deployment is the deployment set
to only
deploy one or something? Well,
it doesn't wanna scale down to one.
And Russell said he hasn't seen out of
pods before. That's when you hit the max
pod limit on a kubelet,
which is a 10. Which which
is 10.
But
something is creating loads
and loads of cluster pods.
These are controlled by a replica set by
five seven nine.
And it wants to keep coming back?
No. I don't I don't think it would
create the same one.
Yeah. I think the worker might have its
own max pods.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You can change your
note name to the control plane and remove
the tint if you wanna just quickly get
this
working.
Alright.
Super hacky mode there. Right?
Control
plane one.
So I get that right? I think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Schedule name Bobs.
And then if you go to get nodes.
Yeah.
Yep.
I guess delete that too. Yep. Can can
you have no spec? Can't. Alright.
It's creating. Creating.
Alright. Let's see if we have a
let's see if we got the dance.
No.
Come on. There can't be any more breaks.
Do we have a service?
We do have a service.
If you click on the service, it does.
I guess, will it resolve to the cluster?
Yeah. Does the clustered service have any endpoint?
No.
You can just enter. If you
if you
k
k nine s usually maps the service to
a pod. Node port. Node port.
This is supposed to be a Node port.
Right? Yeah. It is. It is.
Is there a selector
on the service? Yeah. App clustered.
Is our deployment not got those labels?
Let's see. Is there a network policy still?
We're getting a clue. Ah.
Check the network policy, CRD.
It's just NetPoles?
Oh oh, but yeah.
This was an absolute
dumpster fire.
Not yet. Any settling of network policies?
Are we still getting
There's CMPs and CCMPs.
Nope.
I think the pod hasn't been created yet.
Oh, I thought we got it. I
think it was stuck on container creating.
There's
no there's no oh.
William API client time out.
Alright. I don't think the error spike could
get invited back. Okay.
Maybe try deleting it and restarting it. So
no. Not the don't restart the cube. Restart
the
pod or kill the pod, and then we'll
just see if it gets reset. Sure.
Yeah.
I mean, I think the new one's gonna
also get stuck,
presumably.
Might have still been using the old network
policy or something.
Yep.
I'm still curious to know what's creating this
on the worker.
Yeah. That's a lot of pods for a
replica set set to two.
I guess the Kubla config is maybe still
max pods on one of the node.
I mean, we still have a session over
there, don't we?
And fire that kubelet config dot yaml.
Well, just give us a few more minutes,
and we'll see if we can find whatever
random thing is left here. But oh, yeah.
MaxPods one. There you go.
Strange. Oh, there was something alive there. Was
it or is that the old one still?
What's our newest deployment? This
Yeah. That look that look Nope.
It's still on container creating. Right?
Out of memory, out of disk.
The disk is rather large on these machines.
Yeah. We got tons of tons of memory,
tons of cores.
You I mean, you can remove those limits
and requests. I don't think I even added
them. So Yeah.
I think those are usually
they'll show up in the events. So
You're adding the pods instead of the deployment?
Yep. I
have I can't I can't explain that pod
behavior why there's so many. That's
that's weird.
I'm I'm surprised that I can't seem to
get rid of the replica set that's creating
them,
which is 579.
Right?
Wait. So canines does this is one of
the we've seen this before, actually. Drop out
of canines, and I bet if you delete
it from the CLI, you'll get another message.
We have seen we have seen this before.
That's the key that's can I propagate all
the stuff? Yeah.
If you try to get replica sets and
then try to keep control delete r s
with the name, you'll probably get the correct
error message.
So we want to keep
we wanna get rid of
all of them besides the newest.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you could just delete
every replica set in the cluster if you
really want just to attach that at all.
Like, this deployment controller will bring them back.
That actually worked,
surprisingly.
Alright.
And then
Did they just pull an image maybe?
What node is that? Again.
You start cube
let on control plane.
Don't why. I don't think we need to
It's on control plane. So Okay.
Wait. What's this telling us?
No. No. That's
stuck on creating.
Kill the pod again?
I mean, we deleted the replica stuff. Right?
Yeah.
It shouldn't be a problem.
Postgres is also stuck. So
Oh, post crisis stuck? Okay. Yeah.
Why
what else might be unhappy?
Let's try and get pods all.
I I think canines is our detriment here.
I think it's hiding stuff.
So
Absolute back off on API
DXT.
So we can ignore emissary.
We got one of our Scyllium operators.
That's okay because we only have we don't
have enough nodes for that third one.
Our Scyllium does appear to be okay, although
it has restarted a bunch of times.
We got container creating for a whole bunch
of things. Can we do it all white
on this?
Get pods dash all white.
Yep.
So, yeah, so Postgres hasn't scheduled because of
the scheduler.
Oh, okay. Yep. The scheduler is broken. So
And I'm curious if we describe that clustered
pods,
if we can get any information too.
Oh, okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Great.
There's really nothing.
The pending can only be one of two
things. Right? It's the scheduler, which we've alleviated
by hard coding the node name.
Yeah. Well, do we need to also hard
code the scheduler for Postgres?
We could. But then the fact that the
cluster part doesn't start and tells me that
that's still pending because
either the port isn't available on the node
Oh, is NGINX blocking it? Is
The NGINX
is the is NGINX necessary for this? No.
You can you can get rid of that.
Yeah.
Nothing's on eighty eighty.
I
have no idea what's wrong with this cluster.
Let's let's cluster these.
Alright. Marek, if you're still watching and you
wanna jump on and tell us just for
a couple of minutes what the hell is
going on here, that would be useful. But
I'm there there's so much broken in this
cluster. This is literally a dumpster fire.
Jeff from the team has seen slash run
as full.
And he created RAM discs to eat up
all the memory.
Alright.
I'm happy I'm happy to call it there.
I think that there there's too much broken
here to fix in a couple of minutes.
Yeah. Tricky.
Wow. That was a tough one. Two really
tough clusters for that last Yep. There's there's
slash run.
Was it? Oh, yeah.
You see, you have to scroll up, but
Oh, yeah.
I guess you can't speak to any of
the sockets potentially on that machine. I'm not
sure Yeah. What the side effect of that
is, but not something I've seen before.
Damn. I never got a party with team
aerospike or team pixie labs.
Well,
you know, our eBPF breakfix itself. So
Yeah. I'm not even sure if there's enough
eBPF in the world that could detect that
many breaks in the cluster as well. There
was a there was a lot going on
in this one. But I think you managed
to work through quite a lot of the
the things there. Some of them were particularly
tricky as well, like
the max pods, the run ones. These are
just flags I had no idea existed, which
I think is great because now we all
know that these completely
have to be malicious flags exist,
and we can delete them from all our
links.
Alright.
Thank you so much for joining me, Pixie
Labs. Your breaks were really fun and entertaining
to watch. Fixing that was fun and entertaining,
and thank you to.
So I'll let you skip back to your
day, but thank you again for for joining
in.
Thanks for having us. Awesome. Thank I'm
just gonna pop over here, and I'll do
the t shirt now before I let you
all get away.
Competition.
Winners. Let me pop my screen up.
Alright. Draw. There's
We still got a few of you on
the call. That's alright.
Go.
Who wins?
I don't see names.
I'm sure that they're somewhere. Your friendly cloud
native gopher, I think is the name and
Hervey Nickel. Alright. To find your t shirt,
just DM me on Twitter or email me
at david@rockode.com
or ping me on the Discord. Just get
in touch. Give me your address. I'll get
you those t shirts. Thank you to all
of our sponsors and thank you to everyone
who's watching Equinix by Rawkode and everyone else.
I'm gonna go have a beer. Have a
great day.